hey good afternoon everybody it's mike
it's just coming up on three o'clock uh
central time i'll get started in about
15-20 seconds uh you know it gets
started right on time i don't want to
keep you guys on too long you know it's
friday and uh it's been a it's been a
long week
so it will get started uh in about 15 20
seconds uh right on the hour so
again thanks for taking the time out
today i know everybody's busy and then i
know a lot of people are in different
locations than me you know some guys are
in europe right now i don't think the
asian guys are
guys in asia have woken up yet but um
but if you did manage to get in you know
i appreciate it
so
what i'll be talking about today is our
newest indicator the order flows stratum
indicator and you know one of the
questions i got was you know why you
call it the stratum indicator and
basically you know the the word stratum
you know it's it's got to do with
different layers right and you know
we're talking about layers in the order
flow
and more specifically
layers of volume within the value area
right you know we all know what the
value area is in order flow it's it's
you know it's a market profile term a
lot of people that are familiar with
volume profile also use it you know it's
the area where 70 of the volume
trades and that period it could either
be you know a day period an hour period
a 30 minute period or even you know at a
very micro level but we're going to get
into that so before i jump in and
everything you know just a brief
disclaimer do understand that you know
we're all adults here trading involves
risk only risk capital should be used
for trading only those with sufficient
risk capital should use um should be
trading
so again you know where we came up with
the name stratham is
think of it like this right you look at
the site you know say there's a
earthquake or you know a big mudslide
somewhere and you always see the picture
of the mountain right and you see
you know sort of the different layers of
soil
right and you see where some layers are
thicker more compact others is a bit
lighter
and it's not until you until you look at
it up close and personal that you could
see oh yeah you know what i can see why
this layer held for so long or you know
why this part hasn't fallen down it just
really gives you you know it's like
chopping away at the side of a mountain
what you're doing with the order flow
right you're you're taking a
what is considered
you know a support or resistance right
the value area we all know what value is
and what it means to traders right
traders uh
should think in terms of value and that
can act as your support or resistance
area
and just like the mountain right it's
going to act as your support or
resistance until it starts to chip away
and
what causes it to chip away right or
fall apart sometimes is the different
layers is not very strong and that's
really what the order flows
stratum does is it looks at these
different layers of volume within the
value area to determine you know is this
bullish or bearish so
just really briefly you know the stratum
was born when analyzing the order flow
in the context of value what most
traders do is look at market profiles or
volume profiles and trade the pattern
now what stratum does is it looks at the
order flow taking place in that pattern
right if you've ever read
the great books on
market profile you know the the dalton
books the staddelmeyer books you know
you know that there's different types of
profiles there's just not one profile
that appears over and over you know you
have your distribution days your double
distribution days um you know your
normal your normal variation days etc
but the way
that the volume trades within those
value areas is is different right those
different types of value areas have
different meanings
why is
it's due to the volume that's trading
inside right and one of the reasons why
we decided to really dive deep inside
the volume in the value area is because
that's where the volume is right we
don't necessarily need to be analyzing
the
the outside the value area where there's
very little volume going through
so big moves start right when a market
moves out of value in search of new
value yes we know that but really what
you could do you could take a chart and
you could draw a value area
starting anywhere
right there's no
some traders think there's a hard and
fast rule that you have to start drawing
a value area at the beginning of the day
no you don't you could open up a chart
say you're using a monthly chart you
could start it at
anywhere you want i like to start them
at swing highs or swing lows
you know do i have to start at the
beginning of the day no i can start it
at the cash open i like to anchor it
with a certain point
so
even though you could draw
you know value areas anywhere
really what you want to be doing is
looking at how the volume is developing
in that value area to tell you if it's
bullish or bearish right and remember
each value area is different the way
volume is being distributed
inside the value areas is different so
for example right i just threw up these
these these are just bun charts this is
a bunch heart from i don't know what day
this is yesterday
this is
you know from this
area here from the swing low to the
swing high
volume is here right we got
your just your normal day your normal
distribution right here whereas
from that swing high to the swing low
volume is distributed very differently
so how you're going to trade it is going
to be very different
here's another example right also
you know just from swing highs to swing
lows looking at
sort of the you know these different
value areas how the volume is being
distributed inside
they're all sort of different
right here you got the point of control
on the top of the bar here you got it
sort of up you know near the top again
sort of near the top here you got it you
know in the middle here you got it in
the middle here you got it up near the
top
but the way the volume is being
distributed in here is different here
you got a little void in here um here
you got a little bit of a void here you
know here sort of comes out a little bit
comes out again bigger
sort of you know it's got they all got
different shapes and that's fine
but
watching how the volume in this
sort of pocket here of this range is
being traded is going to give you
insights into the market that not
many people have or are interested in
looking at you know most traders they
like to look at normal bar charts
and
follow price
okay but what is price doing well price
is reacting to where value is forming
so you know one of the
advancements when we released the new
version of order flows trader earlier
this year was being able to put the
value areas on a bar
right and it was very revealing a lot of
traders are loving it and added it
to their training because it gives them
insights as to where value is forming
you know on a bar by bar basis over
several bars
over a period of time over volume
you know it's just giving traders a
whole new perspective but the problem is
for other traders is trying to determine
which value areas have
bullish order flow or bearish order flow
taking place
and again that's where the stratum comes
in is it's going to analyze how the
volume
inside value areas are being distributed
to tell you
right here that this is bullish right
that this is bullish
okay now i'm using the trade entry
signal that's why you don't see the
signal i know that this is the
the bar that was analyzed i know this is
the bar that's analyzed the signal's not
appearing here it's appearing on the
next bar because one you know you want
the bar to close you want to be sure
that
you know the period that you're
analyzing is complete right because you
know you've ever looked at bars i mean
just watching bars develop you know that
sometimes bars start out very bullish
then they end up very bearish
okay and if you're
if you were just
watching
you know price you're thinking hey you
know i gotta get long because this order
flow is looking bullish and you get long
but then the bar reverses and closes
down and you know you're you're long and
wrong so i like to let the bars close um
you know for the confirmation tell you
hey you know what yeah that that was
bullish what happened in there in the
order flow then when the next bar opens
up
you know that's where i'm getting the
signal come in here here
okay so
let's take a look at some real
just starts from today okay because
that's going to give you the best idea
so
the settings very simple okay i'm going
to take you through i'm going to show
you a bunch of different charts from
just today
with the different settings and really
the only settings you really need to
worry about is one is the magnitude
level right of
the strength so to speak you know we
call it the magnitude level um
because you know stratum's got to do
with you know the earth and you know
magnitude you think of earthquake so you
know i want to keep it in line there i
could use the word strength but it it's
the same meaning uh strength level one
through five one being the weakest five
being the strongest three being sort of
the midpoint you could also use two and
four you know some markets
that
uh you know trade
light volume to sort of medium volume
you know you might want to jump in
around two maybe
or you know volume markets that trade a
lot of volume for example
or not volume but have a lot of
volatility you know
then q
russell dax you know you'd use a setting
of five but you also got you know a
slightly weaker one of four to go to but
really the ones i stick around with are
one three and five
and the other setting is the swing
filter
right right here to enable it you'd
click this box so there's a check mark
there and your swing period
basically
you know what you'd be looking for and
i'll show you on the charts
is you're looking for you know swing
highs or swing lows to trade around
right i mean you you ideally if you can
sell a swing high or buy a swing low
that's great right you want to buy high
buy high buy low and sell high
and we're going to do that you're going
to do that around swings basically so
um
let's let's pull some charts here so
really
quick different markets you know
different volumes
different volatility
and
you know
i'll just deal with you know settings
one two three
and five okay i'm not going to talk
about four because honestly it's a fine
line between four and five but um
when you're analyzing a market always
start at one
okay
with the swing filters turned off
settings
of one you know the markets would be
like the ultra 10 years the corn the
five years
the 10 years
so
let's pull up a chart here so what is
this is uh e-minis so let me just go um
well i'll pull up
pull up corn
real quick here
and
i'll just change the setting to i don't
know i got it on here right now this one
looks nice actually this is a setting of
three okay
see right
right in here so swing filter is
swing filter is turned off right there's
no check there
at in this box so it doesn't matter what
you have in the swing period
i'm using a level of three
okay now today in corn
well the agriculture markets they had
their spine demand report came out today
you know supply and demand number in
grains is like the non-farm payrolls or
or even cpi nowadays um
is to equities and and the bond market
so it was a big very big number but
under normal conditions you know you
could use one again you can also use
three you know sort of the higher you go
with magnitude the less signals you're
going to get so this again this was
today
in corn okay
obviously it looks like this is where it
opened but this is when the number
the supply and demand numbers get
released is
11 o'clock chicago time
big move down big move up a little short
here another move up another move up uh
markets closed right now
um but you can see here this is actually
when the market's reopened at 8 30 i
mean it trades at night but then it
reopens at uh
8 30 in the morning and
normally this is how corn trades you
know what you see here this afternoon is
due to the the data release that came
out so this is a setting of one
okay so you know
i was at look on the previous day you
know again
very shortened hours it's a grain
contract but you know here's your here's
your high here's your low
um
you can also adjust again like the swing
filter right say i just want to get the
signals appearing at swing eyes or swing
lows all right
you can enable that and you can change
you know whatever swing period you want
one
five ten i don't think you really need
to go above you know 15
especially if you're into day trader
but let's just see how
how it looks okay so not a lot so you
see it filtered out a lot of signals
because they're not happening in a swing
highs or swing lows so there's a couple
buys there's a cell here's a buy again
that was yesterday
um
this was on the reopen last night but uh
during the day session
here yeah i mean we had that very tight
range right ahead of the number you know
those are short here it doesn't look
like much but it's you know this is what
31 and a quarter down to 28 it's a three
dollar move
that's 150 bucks this is a little bit
bigger move here this one didn't work
out that's with the swing filter on if
you don't want
to use a swing filter you just disable
it
okay like this just uncheck that box
right so you're gonna see a lot more
signals um maybe you just want
a very
you want to filter out some trades but
not
too many a swing filter of five is
looking for a bigger swing higher swing
low a the minimum you could use is one
right so now you're seeing you know here
here you know up here up here you're
seeing a few more trades sorry a few
less trades because you got the swing
filter there
um then when it's off but if it's you
know set to a higher number of five
um you know this one will disappear this
one will disappear
i'm not sure about that one
so this is with the swing filter of five
right so you got
though that one's still there the short
here the short here
um you know if you were to set dust i'll
disable the swing filter and i'll set
the
magnitude level to five just to give you
an idea
okay so here's a very strong setting of
five you see very no swing filter
you're seeing a few moves
okay
you know here here
even here and here
but you know again on a market like corn
that doesn't put in a lot of volume
you might find yourself
waiting around a lot for trades
okay
just sort of going back you know sort of
previous days
you know some quick burst here a little
short there
um
you know just another market that i
think you know doesn't get a lot of
attention is is five years
so let's just pull up five years real
quick here
um let's give it a second here now
you know five years is you know trades
on the board of trade it's a nice
contract trades and quarter ticks
and whoops got the wrong five year
need the future is five year
that is um
again when you're
first adding the stratum to a chart
you don't know where to start again you
know i'll send you these settings i'll
send you guys the slide deck here with
all the different you know markets and
settings
um just so you could have them
but this one is set to what was that
would i leave it on five right
yeah five which is quite high right
that's a bit much um so i'm surprised
that i'm not surprised that there's
a lot of sig not a lot of signals right
that's what i'm expecting
um
you know
in this market
right but you can see you know there's
some nice moves because five is very
strong
for five years you know i prefer a
setting of one
just because it it doesn't
have a lot of volatility on markets that
don't necessarily have a lot of
volatility you know i always like to
start it at one
so just go back to today's
session here
right some nice
you know nice move up nice move down
that's early in the morning
um you know just before 8 o'clock a nice
move up here nice little move up here
nice move down back up down back up you
know five years in my opinion is one of
those markets it just doesn't get uh
just
it doesn't get the love
but
you know if you want to add a swing
filter
just click that box swing period you can
start at one if you want a bit wider
swing period you know you could change
it to three or you could change it to
five
and see it's just calculating up here
so yeah it's got that move down this
move up this little move here you know
that pipe in a scratch but nice to catch
that move down but
um
you catch this move back up
you know move back down
so you know that's the
these are the markets i recommend for
setting up one whether you want to use a
swing filter or not is up to you
but um
you know try it at first with this the
setting at one it said if you think
you're getting too many signals try a
swing filter now two
setting of two
okay so it's a little bit stronger
remember one is the weakest
but
two is the strongest and what it's
looking at it's looking at the
distribution of the volume how strong
it is right in terms of bullishness or
bearishness and the reason as you go
higher you know one two three four five
the more volatile markets right
you got to remember right well you know
what is volatility it's mark it's
price looking for an area to transact
around
if
there's not a lot of volume being traded
like you know for example in dax
then
it's going to take you're going to have
wider value areas
and
the calculations for the stratum take
that into account right that's why you
have
you know a stronger magnitude level okay
so in case you're wondering why isn't
everything just five or everything just
one or everything just three it's
because you know markets different
markets have different volatility they
have um
you know they trade different volumes i
mean you know you can't
trade the nasdaq or the mini russell the
same way you would trade
corn
right i mean most people don't trade
corn and
mini russell but you know some people do
but you know you got to understand that
you know when you're dealing with
different markets there's different
variables inside the market
so
when i say a setting of two anything in
one can also be used too so
again you know anything that you're
using with the setting of one you can
also bump it up to two and and and use
it as well but the other markets that i
like to look at with the setting of two
or even one is you know buns ultra bonds
british pound uh
soybeans gold you know gold's is one of
those tricky markets sometimes the
volatility just ramps up sometimes it
gets a bit quiet
um
and you know just
give you an idea you know i said
anything in two
in two
anything that's used in the setting one
can be used also with setting a two the
same thing would apply when you're going
to setting a three right you could also
you know some of these like buns maybe
you want to have you know not as many
signals so you're gonna use a setting of
three because as the magnitude level
goes up the less signals you're going to
get so
um let's go back to the charts here
okay so what did i say buns fgbl
bonds is a terrific market to trade
if you're in asia obviously if you're in
europe asia it's great because it opens
up in the afternoon and you got it uh
all afternoon to trade it i i
wish sometimes i wish i was back in asia
because um
i like to sleep late whenever possible
as i get older i like to sleep in and
you know trading buns in asia you know
you know to get ready until it's after
lunch time already when the market's
open it's actually it's like
three o'clock four o'clock in the
afternoon so this is buns okay so what
was the setting i think oh this one i
think i got a swing filter on
so it's a swing filter of one right with
the magnitude level of one okay so let
me just turn that off i'll set the
magnitude level at
two because if i had a magnitude level
of one with no swing filter i'd get more
signals which is probably you know most
people get scared they got a lot of
signal oh my gosh what am i doing wrong
so you can see here it's a level of two
right and this is you know if you're a
bit more active you know maybe
that's fine for you you've been using it
show you the difference between one and
two so this is at two
this is one
go back to one
so it's going to be a bit more
right
you see it's just a bit more if i were
to go to 5
it's going to be
a lot less
all right some people may want to use
this you know but but be careful right
because you think oh hey this is great i
mean look i got this you know this move
here
got some moves here
sometimes you know on days like this
right yeah yeah i caught this move here
but you didn't catch anything down there
because you're being too strict
if you go
you know
again if you go down to
two whoops
two
which is what sort of the level that i
like for buns
you're a bit more active on this move
down right to catch that nice move down
yeah sure you get stopped out here you
get stopped out here
you catch a nice little move up here but
you catch that the big move here right
here to here
right from here to here
here back up right again there's
there's a lot of activity in the buns
that you can take advantage of
and again if you want to add a swing
filter on there just click on swing
filter all right it's going to clean it
up a little bit if you think there's
too many signals right
so just sort of go back here
right here this gets this nice beautiful
move down doesn't look like much but
this is a move from you know 80
all the way down into
you know down into the 40s the
dollar move
um you know again just move up it's nice
move down
you know some small moves right in there
um you know another one ultra bonds
ultra bonds obviously for me i think
trade very similar to buns ultra bonds
obviously are in um
30 seconds
this is the same setting that i was
using in the buns right i think
i had a swing filter on of one
but again you don't need to use the
swing filter unless you just want to
filter out some trades i think you know
let's look at this this nice move up
here move down this nice move down let's
move down move up if i had the swing
filter off it's going to give me more
signals
but for me you know sort of the sweet
spot with um ultra bonds is a setting of
two
right so here right you're seeing
a bit more signals because it's not
looking for swing highs or swing lows i
mean the signals are in the same
direction as the moves i mean
this v shape right here
you know
down down down then back up you're
you're being a bit more active if you
were to have it set at say five as a
strength
yeah there'll be signals but
there's going to be a lot less
okay
yeah guys i see your questions coming
through um i'm gonna get to them sort of
at the end
so i don't get sidetracked now but yeah
i i am seeing your questions so if
you've got questions be sure to throw
them in there um deborah i see your
questions steve i see yours
okay so let's set this back to two um
let's just take a look at uh
another market here real quick
where's pounds
you know
currencies currencies i like to trade
british pound euro currency um japanese
yen you know futures wise
those are the contracts that i think are
are tradable i mean you could trade the
other ones like peso and things like
that but
you could there's so many contracts out
there available for trade so this is
british pound
it's a one minute chart british pound
nice thing about that just the same with
euro you could trade it during the
european hours you know there's plenty
of activity but you can see here right
there's some nice moves this is a
setting of two
so again this is starting at one in the
morning
until about 7 30 in the morning
if
i were to
have a setting of one again you'll see a
lot more signals
right
if you
have a setting of two which is what i
recommend the swing period of one
are you going to get is going to filter
out some of the trades
right if you had a
actually a bigger swing filter it's
going to filter out more
but i mean you know that's what training
is about right you get those big moves
right you want to stay with the trend
and when you're wrong get stopped out
when you're wrong get stopped up you
know you just one two three
four bad trades then you can get it back
on this one trade right here
and then you gotta trail your stop
um
just
really quick turn that back put it back
on normal um
let's get things
take a look at wheat oh sorry wheat
soybeans okay again soybeans is also uh
this is a grain contract
they had the number today the big drop
right here
but this is a setting of two right so
let's look at a different day i mean
this is the evening session it tries
decent volume in the evening
sometimes um again you know there's
other contracts you should be trading in
the evening so
a setting of two
you know if you put a swing filter on
it will clean it up a bit
use the minimum swing filter one
and you know let's clean it up so you're
seeing you know shorts in here shorts
shorts shorts
you know this long and didn't really
work out um
you know during the evening session
a lot of asian
there's a lot of trade with grains
during the asian hours
um
you know here's the open obviously yeah
i'm not gonna say yeah you would have
caught that you're not gonna you don't
want to trade on the supply and demand
release
it's it's very volatile but it was
interesting though the number came out
very bearish you see it sold off and it
basically recovered right back to where
it was
um
you know this is a big move for grains
60 cents down to 20 cents
cut down to what is that 15
something 15 and a quarter but that's a
huge move in in grains
that's what
40 cents
it's a 2 000 moves in grains um
okay so let's go back to the settings so
setting the three okay euro currency
e-minis crude oil ultra bonds soybeans
grain uh gold
so like these three again i i say you
can use a setting of two we can also use
a setting of three
um so let's take a look at the charts
here now
one is
setting a three you know you could also
add a swig filter swing filter of uh one
if you like
again you can do that with with anything
um
sometimes you know people get nervous
taking too many trades
they don't want to think a lot but if
you're using us
you know if you're using something like
markers which this works with
it will
it will um
you know call it it'll read those
markers so let's go here magnitude level
of
three
all right so uh
let's just go
start looking at these other markets
crude
hey crudes
it's nice to see the price of
oil come down
again you know
i'd rather the price of oil be lower
than higher just because i use a lot of
uh
gasoline driving driving around a lot
but um
yeah like stocks going up price the oil
going down just
in general that's a personal thing so
okay so this is a setting of three okay
so
all right it's catching this you know it
doesn't look again you know
crude oil has been volatile you know
this year volatile more so than than
ever
and you know as the price of oil gets
higher
you're going to get bigger swings i mean
that's just that's just normal um
you know that was the thing with uh
something like bitcoin right everyone
talks about you know sometimes you have
these
bars or you know bitcoin goes up a
thousand bucks or comes off a thousand
bucks
but it's all relative right they don't
traders those traders they don't really
understand that you know they think oh
look at uh
bitcoin went up
a thousand bucks or bitcoin went down a
thousand bucks well yeah we're trading
fifty thousand it could go up and down a
thousand bucks at least very easily and
when we're trading two hundred and fifty
thousand those swings will be
five thousand ten thousand so while it
doesn't look like much of a move here
it's 94
20 you know all the way down to 92 is
again some more moves there this is a
setting of three if you want you could
add a swing filter to sort of clean it
up a bit
you know minimum of one and you could
use five and if you really want to be a
little bit stricter
i know some people with buyer indicators
like to use um
you know 10 or they're a bit more strict
so you see when you get a little bit
stricter it takes out you know takes out
that short there takes out some of the
shorts
um you know but some decent moves to be
had there in
in this market you know a nice little
move up here
um let's go to take a look at e-mini's
again yeah
go back here right so setting the three
you know euro currency minis again crude
oil ultra bonds you know these three
also
can be used with the setting you can use
you know settings of three five it
doesn't matter you know it all comes
down to your own risk
tolerance and then and what you're
comfortable with so you can see it still
says calculating here so just give it a
second
you know
the thing is you know when
like me you know you can see on if you
can see on the screen but i've got about
25 30 charts opened up down here
um
i like to
yeah i don't flip through you know i
don't change my charts
i don't keep like one chart open and
keep changing it during the day um i'll
just you know
flip through you know like that tabs use
the tab feature
um
so again this is a setting of
what is that three it's got the swing
filter on
so that you're not seeing a whole heck
of a lot of signals but if you turn off
the swing filter
you know you'll probably start to see
some more
because we got this nice rally going on
late in the day
here where
you know it's hard to believe 4280
gosh
acting up a bit slow right now
but again you know
you can
use
different time frames
i did just glance at a question you know
people ask me you know with order flow
right oh i look at a 5 minute chart or
15 minute chart 30-minute chart can use
order flow you can there's certain
aspects of order flow that you could use
on on longer term charts
but again you know you're best served
using order flow the information as
quickly as possible so you know i tend
to stay five minutes and under
um
you know that being said i'll also look
at tick charts and volume based charts
and
not so much range based charts anymore i
just find the market too volatile for
that but
when
you're using you know tick based charts
or volume based charts yeah it's based
on the amount of trades so it can take
more than a minute it could take more
than five minutes sometimes okay so this
is a different dynamics you see this
nice move here from the 50s
all the way up into the 70s again this
is a setting of three
now
when you're getting into the night
session right again there's nice moves
here last night
you know this is like what the 20-ish
area here up there you know this move
down um
sometimes if if i
i'm looking at the night session i will
some markets use a swing filter you
don't have to
if you just find yourself with too many
trades this is yesterday in the e-minis
you know this nice move up this nice
move down
um
again the overnight session right it's
nice move up this nice move down
yeah this was the
on this was the sea i'll say on a plane
this is a cpi number day
you know it's it's hard i'll train such
a big
number like that um especially on a
market that everyone is watching
waiting to see but i mean there's
opportunities in the night session that
you can take advantage of this is
again the previous day you see during
the day session this was on the ninth
which was what monday i believe
i said monday or
i'm sorry that was tuesday not a whole
lot right there was you know once the
cash opened there's this one buy which
didn't really go anywhere the sell this
buy and that was pretty much that was it
for the day
now
setting up
five
okay
again you could use five for every
market out there but
you know on normal markets
when you start ramping it up you're
going to get
fewer signals right and i really
recommend setting a 5 for markets that
are a bit more volatile than most you
know russell
um dax nq mnq
ym i didn't include ym on here you could
get you could use three you could use
four or five you know between you could
put it under five you could put it under
three as well
um
but let's take a look here okay so
uh
let's go to uh rty where are you here
rty
give it a second here so you know these
more volatile markets first time you
load them up it takes a little bit
longer because there's just so much
information
um in my information i mean you know
data it's got to analyze so this is a
setting of what was that
of three
again you know i don't like three
because the market's just a bit
more volatile than um
i like to see
so i like to set it at five and again
the more volatile market is you know you
might want to add on a swing filter
right a minimum of one
um so you see
you know cash open right here 8 30.
let's move down
here again this is about a five-point
move here let's move up pulls back right
to around your entry point and then
takes off again
those two cells didn't really
materialize much this was the overnight
session
again you know the
problem with
market like russell
overnight can be crap at periods like
this during asia
um
this was yesterday's
session
you know and i don't wanna say yeah look
he could have bought here and got that
move
um
during the cash session these were the
moves here you know could have caught
this one hopefully got that move there
again this is the night session kind of
crappy volume so you got some bars it's
just trading it's probably no trade
going on in some of these periods or
it's just you know one trade goes
through at one price it's just looking
like that's
deceiving um you know the day before you
know here's a move here this one took
off it's been
kept going but um you know that's
you know the next day the next day
the previous day tuesday there really
wasn't much right i showed you the
e-minis there's only four trades during
the cash session cash opened up where
right here
on russell there's only one trade here
there's this one short trade
uh
let's take a look at
another volatile market dax
right for you guys in europe that like
to trade
um dax
again the setting of five
okay to show you tax right five right no
swing filter
okay
all right it's a nice move there but
um you know really dax you want to be
trading during european hours all right
nice move up here this moves back up a
little move down this one was nothing
that was nothing um
again
the day before
you know i think you know for people in
america to trade dax you gotta realize
that the the
european
cash market closes like around 10 10 30
i forget
the timings i think it's it's by 10
o'clock volume really after 10 o'clock
the volume really dries up
in dax
but
it's a nice market to trade all right
you can see this nice move here it's
nice little moves here
you know the day before
you know before the cpi in the u.s
came up
um
you know a nice move there
you know even the day before so you can
see these nice moves here right moves up
down back up
and cue
just pull it up here real
quick give it a second to come up here
okay so it's again thing with
uh enqueues it takes some time to to
load the first time right but if you
have it running on your chart you're not
going to have that lag
there
so this is a setting of five
you see during the day
right there's no trades
setting a five is kind of strict
okay
here
there's one trade after close look at
that one trade 920
and
you know if you only get one trade a day
don't you want that one trade
day before
all right
again i'm not saying you know look at
how it worked you know right ahead of
the number
um
that's not one that you want to do
but we'll change it to a setting of
three we'll bring it down a little bit
okay so
now you're gonna see probably
you know some more but uh it's taking a
while
to come up but again you know it's you
just have to have it um
open on your chart or you got to go
through your charts and see you know
which setting really works you know best
for it
so just give it a second here
i know it's still loading
um but really quick you know albert
asked what's the color bands with the
signals well
there's what we call zones i'll get into
this in a minute um
you know zones
basically
you see it's hard to see on this type of
chart because it's kind of small but
like
um
you know here these are what we call the
zones
what that is that's just basically
an alert to me or to the trader that hey
you know what the conditions were met
but the signal is actually on the down
triangle or the up triangle okay
and i'll talk about that in a second so
this is with the setting of three
right
again no swing filter setting a three
so yeah you're getting you know you're
getting more
signals
but i mean is is more really better
right would you rather have less that
are more accurate or more that you know
some people like they can't take
you know they take this trade stop and
get or take this trade fine but then oh
my god i got lose loss here i lost here
okay especially after they had
you know they took this one and maybe
they started opening their screen up at
four in the morning taking first trade
loser second trade winner then loser
loser and thinking ah you know what this
doesn't work
right then the next signal comes up here
and they don't take the trade
you know
then what happens
um so
you know that's just something to play
around with again if i'm looking at net
and q in the night session
three is is okay
again you could use five you could even
use four right three four five i would
not use one or two on and q
if you use one or two you're going to
get a heck of a lot
um
so
you know here we'll set it to four
on the nk i'll just go back here to the
beginning
then i'll take a look at uh
well i'll take a look at the questions
here
okay warren gordon asks what's the best
hours to trade the u.s indices
um
well
obviously the there's the u.s session
right you got that's where you're gonna
have the most volume but honestly i
think it's fine from
about
2 a.m chicago time until
3.
there's there's plenty of volume uh even
you know if you're gonna trade it during
the asian hours you know which is the
evening time chicago time traded around
the japan hours which would be about you
know eight o'clock p.m
until about midnight you know after
midnight until about 1 30 volume just
it's pathetic
so this is a setting of four
right so yeah
yeah there's some buy signals there
today
i don't know
again the day before
still getting that one signal up there
which is nice
i see myself i'm not a big nq trader i
will play around in the mq during the
night session sometimes from trying to
catch a move and i want some action
like say i see something in the es
but um
but you know i know es can move slow
during the asian hour so you know
sometimes i'll try and squeeze something
out of nq or mnq
so again you know this is a setting of
four so yeah buy signal here
sell here buy here
so
i'm gonna get to the questions now but
you know if you're interested you know
the order flows stratum all right you
just go to orderflows.com
stratham
and that'll get you started but let's
take a look at some of the questions
here i'll put the link in the chat
david asks
does this work better than your delta
scalper for scalp and mes
well
there's two different indicators there's
different ways of looking at the order
flow this doesn't look at
delta
okay delta scalper looks at delta so
it's it's really hard to say i mean
i don't know what chart you're scalping
it on um you know if it's like a one
minute or 30 second
it really depends i mean but it's
different aspects of the order flow
right there's more than one way to trade
the markets
uh so let's go back here so
does the markers print steve asked
does the markers print after the bar
closes okay so
that's a good question because i didn't
want to talk about this and i didn't uh
talk about it yet so
that's uh
let's just
choose the market i don't know uh
let's keep it simple wheat okay
um for wheat so what do i got on here
okay i just
i said i'm just using this one for
example purposes okay setting a four
fine okay i mean i could use a three
three or four so i mean four is looks
quite nice actually but
on wheat i like to use
three okay so one of the questions were
what were these these
little
blue and red things are okay so
obviously the red triangles
down are cell signals the blue triangles
up
but this is the actual signal bar here
right that's why it has this blue zone
and i use these as you know sort of
visual markers that if i get into the
trade and the trade starts coming down
into the zone
there's a chance that it's going to fail
right this is an area where i'd be
putting my stop okay now you can turn
off those zones actually you can um just
go in here
and signal box width and just expand
this a bit here
set to five that's five bars out well
signal bar the next four bars if you
change it to zero that would
that would remove it okay so you see
it's not there anymore
okay but again i like to have it just
you know as a visual now there's this
other thing is called the trade entry
signal right
that is on right that's checked so
even though this is the signal bar it's
the buy signal or the cell signal is
appearing in the bar afterwards because
the bar is closed
and it's starting to move
by a certain amount of ticks over a
certain amount of bars so what that
means is it's going to price levels
1 2
over the next two bars
one two
okay if i have this turned off
it will appear actually
on the signal bar
okay right here right here but i use it
because the way i trade
is
i let the order flow
you know i want to have that follow
through order flow going in the same
direction right i don't want to oh i got
a signal here i immediately got to get
long right the signal was generated when
the supply and demand number came out
okay if i got long well only get stopped
out there's no follow through order flow
just like here these two cells
that are appearing
over here
right yeah if you just got short
immediately yeah it worked out
okay or we got long immediately here it
worked out but
i don't want trades like this where you
know even though the conditions are met
it gets short immediately it gets
stopped out so it's going to keep me out
of this trade it's going to keep me out
of this trade right i want
to use the order flow to its fullest
potential right i like to have the order
flow come in and tell me that it's still
bullish even after you have the bullish
order flow set up
okay
so
if you have it turned
on
the mark
trade entry signal turned on then
the signal will appear after the signal
bar is closed and you have that
follow-through confirmation right
if you have it disabled it will appear
as soon as the conditions are met in the
bar so even if the bar is still forming
it will
appear there right it could disappear
because the bar is still forming the
bar's not closed yet
right so it could be bullish very early
then late
it could turn bearish right or bearish
order flow come in to wipe out whatever
bullish order flow was there
then the signal will disappear but once
the bar closes and it prints the signal
it will stay there okay
but the trade entry signal it keeps me
on a trade so it keeps me out of this
short here that went nowhere keeps me
out of this long that went nowhere
that's why i used the train entry signal
deborah asks if i put one for swing
pattern that analyzing a one
yeah you know
okay when you're dealing with a swing
pattern the swing don't think of it in
terms of pattern um
think of it as a look back period right
it's looking back you know you use one
it's going to look back the previous bar
so it's either got to be
higher or lower than the previous bar if
it uses a level of five it's got to be
higher or lower than
the previous five bars okay
so if you have it unchecked then it's
just not even going to look on the past
bars whether it's relation of high or
low relative to that
um deborah wants to use
if she wants to look at crude
give me a second here
um
i'll set a five or an eight range bar
and crude
um
i think five is
way too fast
um let me pull up an eight range bar
here really quick
okay so
this is the eight range
honestly i think eight ranging crude
just due to the volatility is
a pretty fast moving
um
market
it's i wouldn't use i used to use look
at an eight range honestly for the way
crude moves now i mean you're talking
moves you know 94.50 down to 90
basically 92.50
well from here it's 94.80 down to 90 280
two dollar move
in what is that not even an hour
maybe just over an hour
hour and a half
um i think eight range for me at least
is just a bit fast that's all
but if i was using on a fast moving
market i would use a
a higher level you know next level i
would check would be four
you know then obviously the last level
you could check is five but then again
you could also add a
filter so that cleans it up a bit more
you know for this you're catching that
still catching these big moves down
these moves up
and again that's the eight range
chart uh steve asks i'm new to your
order flow tools australia a good place
to start another one like pulse or
something else i like to trade ultra
bonds
um
now it's a good place to start
it's
again i don't know you know
let's go back to the ultra bonds here
uh
ub
ultra bonds is a
there's a great contract trade
you know if you're scalping right you're
just looking for those little moves
right i mean you know what is that like
bucks a tick 3125 catch two or three
ticks on each move
it's happy days
right yeah maybe you could squeeze out a
bit more this is a setting of four right
this is my setting that i rolled over
from
crude just now
but ultra bonds again you could try a
level of two so you want more trades if
you're more active scalper um you're
like he's setting the two
right so you can be a bit more active
you know
tn also ultra 10 years great contract
um since the signal
is after trigger come what when do we
enter as soon as the signals as soon as
it appears i use the trade entry signal
because when i used to automate stuff
um
i did before i had the trade entry
signal i use automation tool markers
which this works with markers
where i told markers you know once the
conditions were met for a trade
you know where the market you know the
signal was there bar closed then it had
to keep moving in the same direction in
the next bar for at least two ticks
take the trade but we took that part of
the automation and we put it in here so
to answer your question
if you're using that trade entry
signal it will appear
after the signal bar if you disable it
it will appear on the signal bar
um can you please explain the logic by
stranded by bringing up a footprint
chart want to understand what in the
footprint chart triggers a signal in
stratum well it's the order flow and the
volume
um
the volume in the value area right how
it's being distributed sometimes it's
normal
sometimes it's not
basically you know it's not all value
areas are are
created the same
um mexican
i'm like
can you tell us more about the theory
behind
that please yeah what value areas are
bullish or are bearish well it's not
that you know it's bullish or bearish
value areas
okay i mean there are value areas that
are bullish and bearish right we do
identify that in our overflows trader
software by
putting on
you know highlighting the value areas
blue or for bullish or red for bearish
but
you know this one is not programmed and
the stratum is not part of the overflows
trader software
and how
this volume is being distributed in here
is telling me is bullish right as
opposed to how the volume and it's not
just how the volume is being distributed
how it's being distributed throughout
the bar
as well right even though we don't
analyze this volume in here we're
analyzing this volume but
we also take into account how it's being
formed in that bar
okay
where the heavier volume is in the value
areas etc right there's a lot of moving
pieces to it if i went into it then
you know honestly
what happens to a lot of my indicators
when i explain them in depth like that
people try to reverse engineer them and
come out
come out with them um
colin can we see nq
three minutes please
yeah um just give me a second here
hit my chart i don't know how it's going
to look on a three minute and q chart uh
it might take a little bit time for it
data to load but we'll pull it off
anyway um do signals repaint
well once the bar closes no they won't
repaint if you are not using the trade
entry signal as soon as the signal
appears
it will paint but
if things change it will disappear but
once the bar closes and it's there then
it won't repaint ever again i mean you
need once the bar closes that's it then
it moves on to the next bar for analysis
does the shadow appear with the
indicator
yeah it does
but again you could enable it you could
disable it you could even um enable it
to appear
longer okay just you know i know this is
ultra bonds but um
you know i know some people like to to
draw it out further
we don't
uh
i mean it could be confusing for some
people but i mean it's up to you how how
far you want to draw it out you know
whether you just want it right on there
you want to draw out further
okay but
um
let me just uh well
let's go take a look at the nq because
that's what you asked for and q this is
my in q chart
um glenn says yeah i think most are
trading could look at those
nqes gold crude yeah that's that's what
we looked at yeah i
i know that a lot of traders trade at
nqes but
i know there's also a lot of traders
that use order flow on on these other
markets and
the reason why they like to use order
they trade these other markets because
sometimes it's a bit easier to trade
um
in that sense because these other
markets tend to follow
supply and demand better um
yeah brian it does require tick replay
question is does this require trick
replay yes it does
um
albert i asked i answered that about the
collar bands
uh john asks what does it look like on a
10-minute time frame
honestly i don't know because i haven't
looked i mean we'll pull it up after
this um
and this three-minute chart
can you show some examples on on
footprint charts yeah i can um
yeah it's
you don't need a footprint chart i mean
you could run it on a footprint chart
uh was my footprint here
you know for for
presentation purposes i'm just using a
bar chart it's a little bit easier but
you can see here right this is it on the
on the footprint chart
all right
this is with the trade entry signal
disabled
right you see stratum there's this mes
it's a one minute chart
again this is just giving me every
signal
because trade entry signal is turned off
tell you what
i will load up a 10-minute chart on here
while that's coming up we'll take a look
at the nq
uh three-minute chart so this is a
three-minute chart
of the nq
i think this was set to four three i
think
so
again
not getting a whole heck of a lot of
trades this afternoon here
this was the day before
what was the setting on this one
set to two again if i were to bump it up
to a higher level
four or five there'd be less signals
this is setting a two on on a three
minute chart you know it's a bit
longer i'll say longer term but
longer than i'm
normally used to looking at you know
these look like small moves but we had
that that big move if you were to
sort of expand this chart up because you
get better idea of these
a little bit you know
this is that shoulder time in asia that
i hate to trade i hate looking at that
sort of that
10 30 to
1 30 time even though there was a nice
late move here
but this is at the junk period of time
that asian junk period um
warren asks yeah i got that question um
is there a template to optimize on it
you don't need to you don't need a
template whether you're using i like to
use white charts just because my eyes
if you're using a black chart
it's still going to appear the same way
so you don't need a special template or
anything you just load it up on a chart
make sure you got tick replay enabled
does it work with forex cfds you know
i'm not a forex guy in the sense of
trading actual forex
i like the futures on
you know the forex futures contracts on
the cme
um cfds dogs you can't get good reliable
data it doesn't need level two it just
needs level one
uh
leela
what do you say one best forex broker
i can't recommend a forex broker
unfortunately
uh warren asked i had several programs
for
platform
leela um yeah ninjatrader's fine
you know a lot of these forex brokers
they got their own platforms um warren
asked several programs which would use a
filter with strathm well
you know stratum looks at order flow my
indicators look at order flow and but
they look at different parts of overflow
so
trying to filter it out with different
indicators
yes
isn't probably
is it something that really
delved into right i mean yeah it's nice
to see uh confirmation with say delta
scalper and stratum and stuff like that
but um
i haven't gone in depth on on that
analysis usually i'll run you know
different indicators
you know every chart is going to have a
different indicator right this is like
for example flow's plow right um close
force right abandon value each indicator
each charge is going to have its own
indicator running on it
sometimes you know you probably
sometimes when you're running a couple
indicators on the same chart you think
well
it it's like kids right i don't say you
prefer one over the other but you know
you find yourself taking trades because
it's got this indicator or as it doesn't
you know you sort of deviate from your
plan a bit that's just me
um
uh john asked for a three-minute e-mini
chart sure
uh
the e-minis here pull that one up here
so that's coming up
let's hold off a bit here i think he's
markers with this but you know if you
can use nt strategy test it with this i
don't know justin um
i don't use a strategy tester i use i
just use markers
um
debra asks is this analyzing each
individual candle bar volume or delta
profile it analyzes the bar
volume
and how it's the bar volume is being
distributed it doesn't deal with the
delta
yeah it's indiv it's based on the
individual bar debra
brian yes it will be uh recording
if i get it up later today and shoot you
the email
[Music]
um okay so while this three-minute chart
is coming up i did load a uh
10-minute chart didn't i
okay so this is the 10-minute chart here
so this is the footprint
in a 10-minute chart you're not seeing
very many signals you know here's one
signal
one short signal there
again it's going to vary you know here's
some shorts that didn't go anywhere
um
i don't know what setting i got on here
i'm gonna come up here
three
i don't know try setting a one
see with the market like
es mes you know it trades a lot of
volume it tends to be distributed
generally
pretty easily pretty evenly rather
um
antonio see i'll get to a 30 second
chart in a minute um it's like bar
volume profile indicator
yeah kind of kind of debra
so yeah says this is like a bar volume
profile indicator lets the trader know
the previous bar says enter to trade
sort of like that it does um
deal with
sort of the problem i don't say profile
in the sense because when you start
thinking a profile you're thinking of
the shapes right but it's really about
the distribution of the volume
in the value area right because when
people start thinking of
profiles right they start thinking of
you know oh it looks like this and that
means something
or you know it looks like this that
right like
here
all right you see
how from the swing load of swing high
right your value area is between this
red and this
green
pro and the
v poc is
right in here right well in this case it
only came down to the value of high then
took off right in this case there's your
value area and just sort of rotate it
around here before selling off
um
okay deborah yeah i can run on a
footprint chart um
this is great yeah you could use it with
support and resistance levels as well
you don't need peter asked do you does
do you need to add other indicators to
help make decisions no you don't um
okay alvarez how to use it with markers
you know i'll probably make a separate
video on that later
tonight or this weekend um i just don't
have time for that
today and it's more of a specialized
thing because not everyone has markers
um
and maybe i'll hook up with pablo and
we'll do a special one
on that where would you like to place
your stop after entering at the signal
well
where would i be looking to place my
stop is below this blue line right below
this blue line
or above the red line
it doesn't mean you have to place it
right there
but once it starts coming in there right
i use this as a visual reference for me
meaning like if it's coming in
do i
you know how am i going to react right
i know that it's getting weaker when it
keeps testing these levels
right if it's nowhere near that level
okay fine i'm happy
so this is a three-minute chart on
es again it's
i
i don't
i don't look at a three minute chart so
um
what's the setting on this one
it's not a chart that i normally look at
is set at two
again you know sort of the higher time
frames you go up you know you might want
to set it at the
lower magnitude level
because yeah over time volume gets
distributed okay
let me see here deborah can you use
yeah you can you could use
you know all the tools in the overflow
trader like the ratios etc as
confirmation
i mean you could use whatever tool you
want as uh
as uh
a confirmation yeah brian um brian asks
could well ryan before i get your
question a good glance could one use
volume bars what would that be no you
could use
volume bars as well
so this is a three minute chart set to
one
i'll pull up a volume chart okay so
brian ask you we're going to do a graph
with all your indicators differences
what they looked at
um
webinar show how it indicators are
better for pullbacks continuation or
reversal moves
okay
yeah you know i've been working on that
off and on um
it i didn't realize i got so i got a lot
of indicators
um
so it's something that is still a work
in progress
uh jerry asks for the footprint chart
would it be possible to have a
horizontal line going across the chart
for imprisonment until the price touched
in the future
yeah i mean
that that would be uh something for the
next uh version of florida illustrator
um deborah asks do you sell the ratio
indicator as a solo product yeah we do
it's um
called market flow trader
okay yeah you know i'll flip out that
the link deborah
um
to yeah
that sort of explains
the indicators
um
i i know brian i i know what you're
getting at there and i know what you're
asking
it's
i i i'm trying to put it into an easy to
read format the problem is it's like i
start writing it and it's just
it's
you know because like different
indicators you know so different
indicators you use some use delta some
use imbalances some use point of
controls some use volume some use value
areas so it's like
i'm trying to
put it together in an easy way but you
know just i'll get that eventually but
jerry
um
yeah you know we
have something
like that
coming out
actually soon but
in the new in the next upgrade of order
illustrator um
we are trying to add that feature into
all the tools on order flow straighter
so anyway guys um you know it's it's
coming up
okay as if um
last question here
let's put this email in there for you
just hit me up on okay
i'll put it in the chat there for you
looking forward to hook up with pablo
ashram yeah you know i'll reach out to
the pablo today and uh
see if we can set something up so again
you know guys i
i just want to thank everybody for
taking the time out today i know it's
you know it's friday we've gone over an
hour
um
and
you know it's it's a lot of uh it's a
lot of time
to take out of your days but again yeah
this is a great indicator if you want to
get it uh now's the time to get it it's
going to uh whoops
it's going to get uh
up in price after this weekend so now's
the time to get it so thanks for
attending and
you know thanks for all your questions
oh
sorry yeah i promised you a 30-second
chart
uh
before we go here
30 seconds
leela today i only got course videos
okay
leela
well the courses you got leela were on
on
on the order flow
right not on the volume profile you know
what i'll send you something on
on profiles
uh
let's make a note here
for you just give me a second to write
it down here
um okay here
uh tony s this is what's the setting i
got here on this 30-second chart
okay this is set to one right which is
the the bare minimum let me just turn
off
this first here these zones
and okay i set it to one
let's set the one but again you know at
one you're going to get a lot of signals
okay so
you know
midpoint a good starting point for
even though i say start at one i know
how es trades that one is going to give
you a lot of signals in the es
thanks elmar
um yeah jerry what the order flows
trader software
you know anytime we do any upgrades
they're always free
mazar ask they offer money-back
guarantee
you know
i don't i don't see
i don't say it in the sales page or
anything like that but you know again
you know if you use it
you know you actively use it and you
know watch the markets
for a couple of weeks it's not for you
in your style of training just hit me up
and i'll refund your money right
i
i the reason why i don't put on there
you know glenn actually thanks glenn i
appreciate that the reason i don't put
on their you know money back guarantee
on the sales page is because you know
sometimes you get people they'll they'll
put it up on a chart
but then 10 minutes like it doesn't work
and you know they don't give it time
right they don't analyze they don't dig
deeper they don't even open up the user
guide to take a look at you know well
what this setting means and how i should
use it you know on a particular market
um so antonius this is a set at
three
okay
this is today you know this is the night
session
it's the day before
you know today is one of those days it's
just flow driven so everyone's just
getting along um
another way you could do it again set
the three if you were to set it at you
know one
a lot of signals you could use a look
back filter
uh
justin i missed the answer to whether
you could use it
i suppose you could use a stretch
gesture it's you know my programmer that
programmed it he does use strategy
tester i don't use strategy tester so
that's why i sort of dodged the answer
to your question
um but i know that he uses strategy
tester i don't know if he's tested it
with strategy tester but i know that he
uses it
and so a lot of the stuff he codes for
me can be used with it
if you get it it doesn't work strategy
tester let me know we'll either make it
work with it or i'll just give you your
money back
um
hey sam
this one
oh you know i didn't get your
email
but i'll make a note of it
um
i'll take a look again maybe it's
i think you changed your email though
you know because i don't recognize that
email so maybe it was just
this didn't get through
in there
yeah just resend it again yeah mike
orderflo.com um
so anyway so here's the 30 second chart
with you know the
filter
swing filter set to one
and
the magnitude level set to one so that's
a little bit better
just sort of go back this is the that
day this is the night session um
again yeah this is the day of the
cpi number came out
oh this is all that stuff here
the day before
tuesday
um
yeah jerry this is being recorded
okay
okay real quick last question last
question
i know i said last question about five
times
um
does it only work on time-based charts
no again you could use you know tick
based charts
or volume based charts let's just uh
take a look at i don't know let's choose
the market here gold
um
well you know what these
this is a 30 second chart on gold it's
quite nice but um
ten years
okay gold because a lot of people trade
are interested in gold let's take a look
at a tick based chart
uh so this is a that's a 32nd in gold
but
thick base chart i don't know 50
called
50 ticks
again you could use volume whatever
volume you want i wouldn't use like
thousands you know usually when i look
at volume based charts i look anywhere
between 200 to 500 um so this is a
setting of i think just one right
one with a look back at one so let's
just
give you something to to think well
we'll use a look back of five
right with the strength of one
jerry i don't know if it will work with
the logic renko bars
but you do need tick replay enabled so
if you don't
if the logic wrinkles don't use tick
replay then you can't use it so this is
a setting of five and one
okay it's not a tick based chart
or for example turn that off and you say
you set it to
five right
deborah's is better than orderful's
pulse well again it looks at different
aspects of
order flow
okay so
here's a tick based chart with it's set
to five with no look back filter
so yeah you got a little chop in here
and then you're catching the major moves
yeah sometimes my indicators are like
you know people say which is the best
indicator well it really depends on how
you want to approach the market
and which market you're trading because
there are certain indicators i think
that are stronger perform better in
different market conditions
right i mean sometimes you know people
say i want to i trade nq on a five
minute chart what can you recommend well
i can't recommend anything for you on
that case but you know they trade nq on
this type of charger they look at a 20
range chart um
so every every one is different in that
sense all right guys um
i'm going to end it there i don't want
to take off everybody's friday it is
friday so again get the indicator just
go to orderflows.com
stratum i know i've sent you i'll be
sending out another email later with the
replay anyway
and there'll be the link in there okay
so
again you know thanks for taking the
time out today and i hope to
see a lot of you guys using this thanks
and bye bye
you